[Music]
Amanda Klutz is that with her first
children's book and it aims to inspire
readers to go anywhere do everything and
see anyone Amanda hopes tell me your
dreams will create a safe space for
children to express their hopes and
dreams all while preparing them for
Sleep Amanda Coots is the co-host of the
talk which airs right here on CBS Amanda
good morning good morning Amanda looking
like spring absolutely
um so first of all thank you you sent me
and Marion a book uh and we read it to
Celine we've already read it to her
twice and you say that this is the book
is actually based on a nighttime routine
for your son Elvis we are in the midst
of developing a nighttime room okay
um so tell me a little bit about that
yeah well just so you know those
nighttime routines change over time good
to know yup so this one you know I was
sitting with Elvis One Night in a
rocking chair and we had said our
prayers and sang songs and he still
wasn't ready ready to go into his crib
and so I just said do you want me to
tell you your dreams and then I just
started creating this fantastic
Adventure that he got to go on and it
Incorporated all the things that he
loves trash trucks and airplanes and
choo choo trains and Dada because I
thought you know I'm always trying to
incorporate ways that he can you know
have yeah remember his dad and meet up
with his Dad and it became our nightly
routine and then after a while he
started interacting with me and I would
say a bit trash truck comes in your room
what color is it and he would say green
and then it just became like our little
thing and then every night I would say
do you want me to tell your dreams and
he would go yes it's a beautiful book
it's the perfect length and usually with
grown-up books if you say the book put
me to sleep that's a bad thing but like
for this for a kid's book that's so true
this is perfect it's the right length
and it ends with sweet dreams thank you
yes I I do believe that children's books
are also for adults
um and I think that adults appreciate
when a children's book is very uh to the
point simple but not simplistic it's
soothing it has the right Rhythm yeah
it's very it's it's almost meditative
thank you this is a dream come true for
you right it is a dream come true you
know you always wanted to write a
children's book you know right after
Elvis was born I just was so inspired I
think you guys can all relate our
children just Inspire us and you know no
matter what we're doing if we're making
up a lullaby or or playing a game that
we've just like created in our heads you
know we think we're brilliant we're like
this this is an amazing little you know
lullaby I'm singing that I'm making up
at the time but I think we get into
these these things and then we forget
what we've done you know like time
changes us and and we keep you know
moving on and you forget the things that
you created with them when they were
little I'm just so grateful for this
book because it's like a little time
capsule of this routine that Elvis and I
did when he was two and we still do but
you know one day we'll be able to look
back on and be like that's what we did
when you were a little baby I'm just so
glad to see you Amanda in in this way
because we first met you because Nick we
tragically lost Nick to Cove and it was
so shocking he was healthy and big and
strong and this was in the early days
and I remember every day you would go to
the hospital and you would sing to him
and I just wonder how you're doing in
terms of love in your life even when you
walked in you said Nick gave me these
shoes so I know that you think about him
often and always with your son yeah I'm
gonna have you how do you keep his
memory alive for Elvis who was so very
young and how are you navigating finding
love again in your life are you even
open to that at this stage yes well
we've I've just always made it a point
to keep Nick in our household you know
with pictures up but I mean we we tell
stories all the time I you know we play
his music I mean Elvis is his father
incarnate I mean he constantly is doing
things that remind me of Nick and you
know things like this book it just you
know keeps him alive even though he's
gone from this Earth it keeps him alive
in our house and in in what we talk
about and absolutely I love love I'm so
open to love and I'd love for Elvis to
have a wonderful man in his life that
you know loves us and wants to be a
family so I'm I'm definitely open to it
and ready for it if you know if and when
that comes my way well we are cheering
you odds book is wonderful and it's
going to help a lot of children who've
also lost a parent I think because yeah
is important for them too man includes
always great to have you thank you guys
fabulous we love you thank you so much
thank you thank you tell me your dreams
is on sale right now